WITH WEAPONS BUT THEY ARE WON BY
MEN.
SEE YOU ON AMERICANS NEWSROOM
TOMORROW MORNING BRIGHT AND
EARLY, 9:00 A.M.
HERE'S TUCKER.
>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
IF YOU'VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE NEWS LATELY, YOU'LL ARE
PROBABLY CONFUSED ABOUT A BUNCH
OF THINGS.
BUT YOU KNOW ONE FACT FOR SURE,
JAMES COMEY IS A BETTER PERSON
THAN YOU ARE.
HE IS A VIRTUOUS MAN, HONEST,
DECENT, CHIVALROUS.
INTEGRITY MIGHT BE HIS MIDDLE
NAME ALTHOUGH HE WOULD NEVER
ADMIT IT BECAUSE HE'S ALSO
INCREDIBLY HUMBLE.
HE DOESN'T MAKE THE KIND OF
GRUBBY MORAL COMPROMISES FOR
YOUR SAD MEDIOCRE LIFE.
HIS IDEALS ARE HIGH AND HE LIVES
THEM.
HE HAS SAID THAT REPEATEDLY AND
CABLE NEWS INTERVIEWS SO
OBVIOUSLY IT'S TRUE.
HOW GOOD OF A PERSON?
HE LEFT THE FBI AND HE'S NOT
GIVING LECTURES ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT MATTERS, HOW TO
UNRAVEL INTERNATIONAL MONITORING
LAUNDERING FRAMES OR STOP DRUG
TRAFFICKING, THAT WOULD BE TOO
OBVIOUS AND TOO TEMPORAL.
INSTEAD, HE'S TEACHING US ABOUT
LEADERSHIP, HOW TO BE BETTER
PEOPLE.
HIS IS A MORAL MISSION.
>> I COULD BE USEFUL BY OFFERING
PEOPLE A VISION OF WHAT ETHICAL
LEADERSHIP LOOKS LIKE.
>> Tucker: IT'S HILARIOUS
ACTUALLY.
BUT IT'S NOT THAT SURPRISING.
KEEP IN MIND HYPOCRISY IS A
SIGNATURE FACT OF THIS MOMENT.
WHATEVER PUBLIC FIGURES ARE
SCOLDING YOU FOR DOING, THEY ARE
ALMOST CERTAINLY DOING
THEMSELVES, AND AVIDLY, IF IN
SECRET.
THE ONES WHO LECTURE YOU ABOUT
FEMINISM TURN OUT TO BE
PREDATORS.
EVERY GUN ACTIVIST SEEMS TO HAVE
A FARM TO GUNNING IT ARMED
BODYGUARD.
THE DOJ LONG AWAITED
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT ACCUSES
COMEY OF PURSUING HIS OWN
AGENDA.
THAT'S NOT A SMALL CHARGE IN A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY BUT
AGAIN, NOT SURPRISING IN THIS
CASE.
MR. POLSON, THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANK YOU, I ENJOYED YOUR
MONOLOGUE.
>> Tucker: IT WAS HEARTFELT.
I STILL AM A LITTLE SHOCKED BY
WHAT WE KNOW.
OR WHAT WE THINK WE KNOW, THERE
ARE LEAKS ABOUT THIS IG REPORT,
AND WE WILL SEE, IT'S COMING
OUT, 500 PAGES OR SO, SOON.
BUT WHAT WE THINK WE KNOW, COMEY
IS BEING ACCUSED OF
INSUBORDINATION WHICH IS NOT A
SMALL THING IN THE FBI, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> IT'S GROUNDS FOR DISMISSAL,
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW ORDERS AND
THEY HAVE TO BE LAWFUL ORDERS.
YOU ARE OBLIGED TO FOLLOW AND IF
YOU DON'T, THEY GET RID OF YOU
AND RIGHTLY SO.
>> Tucker: SO ASSESS WHAT WE
THINK THE IG REPORT SAYS ABOUT
HOW HE HANDLED THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATIONS, IN LIGHT OF YOUR
OWN EXPERIENCE WORKING ON YOUR
OWN INVESTIGATIONS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE JOB HE
DID?
>> I THINK WE WOULD HAVE TO DO A
TERM PAPER ON THAT, TUCKER.
YOU COULD DO A MASTER'S THESIS
ON ALL THE THINGS THAT WENT
WRONG IN THAT CASE.
FROM THE VERY FIRST DAY HE DID
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE, WHERE HE
EXONERATED HILLARY CLINTON, AND
THEN REOPEN THE CASE ON THE
ANTHONY WEINER MATTER, WE ALL
KNEW THAT WAS WRONG.
WE KNOW THAT SOMETHING YOU DON'T
DO, YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE THE
IG TELL YOU THAT, IF YOU EVER
COME IN ON A MAJOR INVESTIGATION
IN THE FIELD OF VISION, YOU KNOW
THAT YOU DO NOTHING THAT WILL
AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF AND
ELECTION.
AND HE IGNORED THAT.
I WAS FLABBERGASTED WHEN I SAW
HIM DO IT.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT HOW
HE DIDN'T LET THE FBI TO HIT
THEIR JOB, AND HE ACQUIESCED TO
NOT HAVING A GRAND JURY.
I WAS ONLY THERE 31 YEARS AND I
NEVER SAW THAT, BUT MAYBE I'M
MISSED THAT.
THEN HE CALLED IT A MATTER,
ACQUIESCED TO THE LORETTA LYNCH
ISSUE.
BEING A LEADER DOESN'T MEAN YOU
LEAD AND CALM WATERS, YOU FIGHT
THE HEADWINDS AND HE JUST NEVER
DID THAT.
HE NEVER PUT ON HIS FBI HAT,
ALWAYS WEAR HIS DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAT AND MADE DECISIONS
HE HAD NO BUSINESS MAKING.
I HAVE A BIG PROBLEM WITH HIS
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: YOU SAID YOU WERE
THERE FOR 31 YEARS AND SAW A LOT
OF INVESTIGATIONS TAKE PLACE.
AND YOU NEVER SEEN A SITUATION
LIKE THIS WERE A GRAND JURY
WASN'T CALLED.
IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID?
>> ABSOLUTELY THAT'S WHAT I
SAID.
FROM THE MOST IN YOUR
INVESTIGATION TO THE MOST MAJOR
INVESTIGATION, YOU CANNOT DO
YOUR JOB AS AN AGENT OR
COMMANDER, OR PROSECUTOR,
WITHOUT A GRAND JURY.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A MAJOR
INVESTIGATION OF NATIONAL
IMPORTANCE AND HE ASKED
ACQUIESCED TO NOT BEING ALLOWED
TO HAVE A GRAND JURY, HE COULD
HAVE GONE TO CONGRESS.
HE SHOULD HAVE DONE A LOT OF
THINGS.
YOU HAVE TO BUCK THAT HAD WATER
SOMETIMES AND HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
AND I THINK IT FRANKLY SHOWED A
LACK OF COURAGE.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THEY DIDN'T
WANT A GRAND JURY?
>> THEY DIDN'T WANT TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
IF YOU BRING PEOPLE IN FOR THE
GRAND JURY, YOU CAN GET GRAND
JURY SUBPOENAS, YOU CAN COMPEL
TESTIMONY, YOU CAN COMPEL
IMMUNITY, YOU CAN SUBPOENA
DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION.
WITHOUT THAT TOOL YOU ARE JUST
BEGGING FOR COOPERATION.
THE FBI NEVER LOOKED AT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY -- I'M SORRY,
THE SERVER THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAD THAT WAS SUPPOSEDLY HACKED.
THEY NEVER GOT THAT, THEY SAID
NO.
WELL, WITHOUT A GRAND JURY, YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO GET IT.
THIS IS NOT THE BOY SCOUTS
TRYING TO SELL YOU SOME CANDY OR
SOMETHING.
WHEN THE FBI COMES TO THE GRAND
JURY, THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO
DO.
>> THIS TALKS ABOUT HOW THE FBI